das bundeskriminalamt hat neue zahlen
veröffentlicht und das ergebnis ist
schockierend an jedem einzelnen tag
werden im durchschnitt zwei mädchen oder
frauen in deutschland von männergruppen
vergewaltigt ja gucken wir immer darauf
hat diese zahlen die nur aus gekommen
sind weil wir jetzt gefragt haben also
bisher wurde das gar nicht als statistik
geführt im vergangenen jahr wurden 704
gruppen vergewaltigungs verfahren
geteilt 704 2009 10 waren 710 2018
minimal weniger nur 6 159 fälle also
daraus können wir schon sehen das ist
ein absolut neues gewalt phänomen und
jetzt schauen wir einmal auf die
herkunft der täter denn das ist
interessant dass jeder zweite dieser
tatverdächtigen in diesen fällen keinen
deutschen pass hat großteil der
verbrecher kam aus islamischen ländern
eben aus afghanistan aus syrien aus dem
irak bei gruppen vergewaltigung stellen
afghanen im moment einen
überproportional hohen anteil der
tatverdächtigen da 2 18 16 prozent bei
nur 0,3 prozent bevölkerungsanteil also
überproportional viele afghanen
überproportional viele tatverdächtige
aus islamischen herkunftsländern bei uns
im studio ist weiterhin unser bild live
chef claus strunz klasse 10 wir diese
zahlen werden in dieser sendung auch
über einen abschiebestopp hier
diskutiert jetzt sehen wir aber
besonders viele straftäter kommen aus
aus aus afghanistan dort wo die taliban
auf dem vormarsch sind dort wo viele
menschen mit dem tode bedroht sind und
zuflucht suchen und gleichzeitig sehen
wir diese zeilen wie erklärst du dir
diese entwicklung also erstmal bin ich
froh dass wir die zahlen sehen denn sie
hat er ohne die nachfrage von bild gar
niemand veröffentlicht weil nämlich
dieses delikt gruppen vergewaltigt und
gar nicht als solches delikt betrachtet
worden ist oder noch schlimmer ist ist
so betrachtet worden
aber niemand hat alarm geschlagen ich
komme gleich nochmal zurück und deine
frage zu beantworten natürlich genau
diese sechs prozent
sind diejenigen um die es geht und da
kann es keine frage geben natürlich
müssen die wenn sie rechtskräftig
verurteilt sind sofort nach afghanistan
abgeschoben werden in gegenden in denen
es sicher ist natürlich nicht in die
taliban hochburgen ich sage ganz ehrlich
jetzt abseits des humanismus etwas dazu
und wenn man sich dort dann doch in
einer situation wiederfindet dass sie in
einem taliban region kommen dann sind
sie eben dort aber sie sind immerhin
nicht mehr hier unser gastrecht ist das
haben wir vorher formuliert verwirkt was
mich daran an diesen zahlen die sind ja
schockieren zwei gruppen
vergewaltigungen pro tag wenn mich
vorher jemand gefragt hätte dann hätte
ich gesagt na ja also vielleicht mal
einem monat oder so aber ich hätte schon
gesagt das ist ein bisschen mehr
geworden
einfach aus medien konsum aus dem was
man hört was man sieht aber 700 im jahr
zwei pro tag wo sich männer mehrere
männer über eine frau her machen und sie
misshandelt und vergewaltigt
man muss es einmal so aussprechen damit
einem klar wird worüber wir da reden das
ist eine neue delikts gruppe die sich
offensichtlich seit 25 10 216 langsam
aufgebaut hat in der fallzahlen und
niemand hat alarm geschlagen
es ist quasi die kölner domplatte mit
anderen mitteln
da hat es auch geheißen nein das ist
kein besonderes delikt und hinterher
jetzt sind sich alle klar natürlich hat
das was mit dem kulturellen hintergrund
der täter zu tun
hier ist es genauso und mich treibt um
warum hat keiner alarm geschlagen kein
sozialarbeiter keine polizistin kein
polizeipräsident kein statistik pfleger
der irgendwo die zahlen sie dann abends
nach hause geht und seiner frau erzählt
ich habe etwas gesehen das glaubt man
nicht kein staatsanwalt kein niemand
kein innenpolitiker niemand hat darauf
hingewiesen wenn wir nicht gefragt
hätten nach dem fallen der wirst immer
noch aber warum warum findest du eine an
ich gebe zwar eigentlich sein was war
das nicht sein da ich habe zwei also
erst mal ich feststellen jeder der es
wusste in behörden in ämtern in
freundeskreisen der die zahlen kannte
und nicht darüber geredet hat ist
mitschuldig an jeder neuen tat
das muss man einmal so hart aussprechen
wenn man einen über ein wissen verfügt
einer so wichtigen sache die geeignet
ist das gesellschaftliche zusammenleben
komplette zerstören
dann macht man sich mitschuldig wenn man
schweigt jetzt zu deiner frage ich sehe
zwei motive motiv 1 jemand ist wirklich
der meinung dass veröffentlichten man
lieber nicht weil der schaden der
veröffentlichung bestimmte gruppen zu
stigmatisieren die damit nichts zu tun
haben also eine ausländerfeindlichkeit
zu schüren dürfe man nicht riskieren sei
nicht verhältnismäßig ich finde diese
abwägung falsch aber ich habe respekt
vor ihr keinen respekt habe ich vor
das darf man jetzt halt nicht sagen oder
wenn ich das sage ich mit meinem chef
oder wenn ich das als politiker zu
meiner sache mache dann bin ich in afg
verdacht dass alles akzeptiere ich nicht
jeder mindestens jeder der in einem amt
oder einer funktion ist hätte alarm
schlagen müssen jetzt haben wir den
alarm
und jetzt müssen wir nach vorne blicken
was daraus folgt